ce lieu est le principal site
archéologique du
pays il y a un truc
là-bas ça doit être un renard ici chaque
nuit un groupe de volontaes armés
s'assure que les djihadistes de daesh ne
viennent pas s'emparer du
lieu notre crainte ce n'est pas juste
daesh il y a aussi les pilleurs et plein
d'autres
menaces c'est notre patrimoine notre
histoire
c'est la chose la plus précieuse que
nous
possédons on la défendra jusqu'à notre
dernier
souffle ce site pour lequel ce jeune
homme est prêt à
mourir c'est l'eptis
magna une ville romaine datant du 2e
siècle avant
jésuschist un joyau
archéologique
unesco depuis la Révolution cette cité
sub aucune dégradation et cela grâce à
cet
homme je suis né à
magna cette ville je
l'aime c'est une partie de
moi-même j'en suis fier
depuis la libération de la
ville il y a environ 5 ans et
demi nai jamais bougé
d'ici n'est pas un militaire il a 60 ans
il travaille dans une centrale
électrique à quelques kilomètres des
ruines ci qui a l'idée de fonder cette
mil de volonir pour éiter que siteit
pé aujourd'hui ils sont 70 à se relayer
[Musique]
ama Salah
Ali ce sont de vrais
patriotes la plupart travaill mais ils
viennent sur leur temps libre pour
protéger le
site malgré la guerre Lesna n'a pas
fermé ses portes au visiteurs et
aujourd'hui est devenu une
attraction
lui c'est un héros oui il est venu ici
et il a
dit je vais protéger la
Libye tu es la mémoire vivante de
l'ptis pourtant quand on me voit comme
ça on dirait un vieux
maboule il y a 5 ans les libien rêv de
liberté et de
démocratie aujourd'hui comme Al il
n'aspire plus la paix et à la
sécurité mais la Libye est toujours une
poudrière prête à exploser aux portes de
l'Europe